This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. A good neighborhood should accomplish a number of important functions. A good neighborhood keeps people safe. A good neighborhood makes you feel like you're a part of something. A good neighborhood makes the lives of its residents just generally good. Not all of us were lucky enough to grow up in a neighborhood like that, But for over half a century, millions and millions of kids around the world at least got to experience it through their television sets.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。一个好的社区应该具备许多重要的功能。一个好的社区能保障人们的安全。一个好的社区能让你感到自己是集体的一份子。一个好的社区能让居民的生活总体上变得美好。我们并非都有幸在这样的社区中长大，但半个多世纪以来，全世界数以亿计的孩子至少通过电视机体验过它。
the world and how to interact with people and how they think life should be. This is Anna Koday. She's a journalist who covers the built environment and public space for the New York Times. Like, it's actually shaped not only children's education, but also our physical built environment. Like, at this point, there are actual streets that are renamed Sesame Street in cities across America. Recently, she wrote about one of the most influential city blocks in the world, Sesame Street. Like millions of other kids, Anna grew up an Elmo fan, which is what kind of inspired the article. I selfishly wanted to see the set of Sesame Street, so I was like, how can I come up with a story that fits into my beach? Is there just like something fun and silly we could do with one of the Muppets?
世界，以及如何与人互动，以及他们认为生活应该是什么样子。这是安娜·科戴。她是一位记者，为《纽约时报》报道建筑环境和公共空间。它不仅塑造了儿童的教育，也塑造了我们的物理建筑环境。目前，美国各地的城市甚至有以“芝麻街”命名的街道。最近，她写了一篇关于世界上最具影响力的街区之一——芝麻街的文章。像数百万其他孩子一样，安娜从小就是艾摩的粉丝，这正是启发她写这篇文章的原因。我自私地想看看芝麻街的布景，所以我心想，我该怎么构思一个符合我报道方向的故事呢？我们能不能和其中一个布偶做点有趣又傻气的事情？
Like, could Elmo show us around his apartment, like an apartment tour? By the way, I'd 100% watch the Elmo Architectural Digest. I was thinking more and more, and I was like, we don't really see that much of his home. It's not really about that. It's more like the neighborhood and the community. For over 50 years, Sesame Street has been teaching children language, math, and core development lessons. But Anna contends that the show has also been quietly educating kids about good urbanism and what a healthy neighborhood should look like. After my article came out, I had a lot of people reach out and say,
比如，艾摩能不能带我们参观他的公寓，就像公寓导览那样？顺便说一句，我百分之百会看《艾摩建筑文摘》。我越想越觉得，我们其实没怎么见过他的家。重点不在那儿。重点更多在于社区和邻里关系。50多年来，《芝麻街》一直在教孩子们语言、数学和核心发展课程。但安娜认为，该节目也一直在潜移默化地教育孩子们什么是良好的城市规划，以及一个健康的社区应该是什么样子。我的文章发表后，很多人联系我说：
You know, I think this is why I always wanted to live in a walkable neighborhood was because I watched Sesame Street growing up, and that kind of shaped my idea of how life should be. And what's funny is, like, on the show, you see Muppets, you see children, and you see adults. So you have all these different ways of kind of imagining life. But in order for us to tell you how to get to get to Sesame Street, we first need to begin with a woman named Joan Gantz-Cuny. Research is woven into the total fabric of the show. Every segment is being tested and evaluated by the toughest critics of all, the children themselves. I think it's fair to say that by the time our program goes on the air, it will be the most thoroughly research show in the history of the medium.
你知道，我想这就是为什么我从小看《芝麻街》长大，所以一直想住在步行友好的社区，那种经历塑造了我对生活应有样子的构想。有趣的是，在节目中，你会看到布偶、孩子和成年人。所以你拥有了所有这些想象生活的不同方式。但为了告诉你如何前往芝麻街，我们首先需要从一位名叫琼·甘茨·库尼的女性说起。研究贯穿了整个节目的脉络。每一个片段都经过最严苛的评论家——孩子们自己的测试和评估。我认为可以公平地说，当我们的节目播出时，它将是该媒介历史上研究最透彻的节目。
Joan Ganscuny was this media executive. She had just won an Emmy for this documentary she'd done on the War on Poverty Program. And, yeah, naturally cute little monsters are next. No, but she viewed television as this tool-to-effect change. Cooney was a former journalist-turned television producer who was galvanized by so many of the social issues plaguing 1960s America. And working on the documentary made Cooney deeply aware of the inequalities in early childhood education specifically. In 1966, the same year she won the Emmy, she worked on this study.
琼·甘茨·库尼是一位媒体高管。她刚刚凭借关于“向贫困宣战”项目的纪录片获得了艾美奖。当然，接下来自然就是可爱的怪兽了。不，她是将电视视为一种推动变革的工具。库尼曾是一名记者，后来转型为电视制作人，她被20世纪60年代困扰美国的诸多社会问题所触动。参与那部纪录片的工作使库尼深刻意识到幼儿教育中存在的不平等。1966年，也就是她获得艾美奖的那一年，她参与了一项研究。
called the potential uses of television in preschool education. Television programming at the time was described as a, quote, vast wasteland by the then FCC chairman. But Cooney realized that if television was already capturing the attention of children across the country, that power could be harnessed and put to good use, particularly if it were a television show for young children. She wrote that more households have televisions than bathtubs, telephones, vacuum cleaners, toasters or a regular daily newspaper. So she viewed the TV as this
名为《电视在学前教育中的潜在用途》。当时的电视节目被当时的联邦通信委员会主席称为“巨大的荒原”。但库尼意识到，如果电视已经吸引了全国儿童的注意力，那么这种力量就可以被利用并发挥良好作用，特别是如果它是为幼儿制作的电视节目。她写道，拥有电视机的家庭比拥有浴缸、电话、吸尘器、烤面包机或定期订阅日报的家庭还要多。所以她将电视视为一种
tool that everyone had this accessible way to educate people and especially kids. This study led to the creation of the Sesame Street Workshop. When the workshop goes on the air, the puppets you'll see in the film
每个人都能接触到的教育工具，尤其是对孩子而言。这项研究促成了“芝麻街工作室”的成立。当工作室开始播出时，你在影片中看到的布偶
will be joined by real people who will set each segment into the proper learning context, recognition of the letters of the alphabet, numbers, basic reasoning skills, and a better awareness of themselves and the world around them. Another person worth mentioning here is John Stone, who is also one of the early creators of the show. John Stone was a writer, producer, and director,
将与真人一起，为每个片段设定适当的学习情境，包括对字母表、数字的识别，基本的推理能力，以及对自身和周围世界更好的认知。这里还值得一提的是约翰·斯通，他也是该节目的早期创作者之一。约翰·斯通是一位编剧、制片人和导演，
and had a huge hand in shaping the look and feel of what Sesame Street would eventually become. According to Stone, he drew his inspiration from one of the most unlikely sources, New York City. The subways are crummy and they're dangerous. You get pushed, you get shoved. Sometimes you get mugged in the subway. Well, I guess I'll pull back a little bit. The city was not doing well at the time, and people were not viewing the city positively at the time.
他在塑造《芝麻街》最终呈现的外观和感觉方面发挥了巨大作用。据斯通说，他的灵感来自最意想不到的来源之一：纽约市。地铁又破又危险。你会被人推搡。有时在地铁里还会被抢劫。好吧，我想我得收回一点。当时城市状况不佳，人们对城市的看法并不积极。
In the late 1960s, New York City was struggling with crime rates and social unrest. People were leaving the city in droves. There was riots, and at the same time, suburbs are starting to grow, and we're in this post-war housing boom, and wealthy white people are moving out to the suburbs in hordes. And this would later be called white flight, of course. All that is to say that cities were not viewed as the place to be at that time, especially New York people who could leave and who wanted to leave were, in fact, leaving. But around this time in 1968, a public service campaign was launched by the New York Urban Coalition
20世纪60年代末，纽约市正苦于犯罪率和动荡的社会局势。人们成群结队地离开城市。发生了骚乱，与此同时，郊区开始发展，我们正处于战后的住房繁荣期，富有的白人大量搬往郊区。当然，这后来被称为“白人群飞”。总而言之，当时的城市并不被视为理想的居住地，尤其是纽约，那些能离开且想离开的人确实都在离开。但大约在1968年，纽约城市联盟发起了一项公共服务运动，
to convince people to care about the city's blighted neighborhoods and to stop leaving town. It was called the Give a Damn campaign. Almost half of all non-whites are forced to live in substandard housing. You can help them through the New York Urban Coalition. And there was a television ad that was part of it and it showed children playing in gutters in Harlem. And it had the tagline again, Give a Damn.
旨在说服人们关心城市中破败的社区，并停止离开。它被称为“给予关怀”（Give a Damn）运动。几乎一半的非白人被迫居住在不合格的住房中。你可以通过纽约城市联盟帮助他们。其中有一个电视广告，展示了孩子们在哈莱姆区的排水沟里玩耍。它的标语再次强调：给予关怀。
Give jobs, give money, give a damn. John Stone, who was working on Sesame Street, he didn't have a clear idea of what it was going to be at the time, but he's working on this children show, and he's kind of watching the TV, and he sees this ad, and it's this, like, epiphany moment for him. He's like, wait, I've got it. It needs to be set on a city's streets.
提供工作，提供金钱，给予关怀。当时正在制作《芝麻街》的约翰·斯通，对节目最终会是什么样子并没有清晰的概念，但他正在制作这个儿童节目，看着电视，看到了这个广告，这对他来说是一个顿悟时刻。他心想：等等，我明白了。它必须以城市街道为背景。
And actually, so after my article came out, his children wrote to me, and I would have loved to have interviewed him if he was still alive, but his children wrote saying that he loved to tell the story, of, like, when he had the idea to set the show on a street, the color from Joan's face just drained. She was just like, wait, what? Like, how are we going to do that? Stone and his set designer scouted locations around Harlem, the Upper West Side, and the Bronx
事实上，我的文章发表后，他的孩子们写信给我，如果他还活着，我真的很想采访他，但他的孩子们写道，他很喜欢讲这个故事：当他想到把节目背景设在街道上时，琼的脸色瞬间变得苍白。她当时就像是：等等，什么？我们该怎么做？斯通和他的布景设计师在哈莱姆区、上西区和布朗克斯区考察了地点，
to build an amalgam of what the brownstone of 1,2,3 Sesame Street would look like and chose not to polish away some of the rougher details. There's trash. There's like wheat paste posters. There's, I mean, Oscar lives in a trash can. And I mean, and it's not just that he lives in the trash can. There's like actual litter on the streets. And the brownstone is not this like pristine brownstone.
以构建出“芝麻街123号”褐砂石建筑的综合体，并选择不掩盖一些粗糙的细节。那里有垃圾。有贴满海报的墙面。我的意思是，奥斯卡住在垃圾桶里。而且不仅仅是他住在垃圾桶里，街上还有真正的垃圾。那栋褐砂石建筑也不是那种一尘不染的建筑。
It has soot on the sides. And you can see that it just looks like a real city street. They didn't beautify it. But in a way, a New York City block was really the only place Stone and Cooney could. set a show like Sesame Street. And this was because of who they were trying to reach. The show was very much aimed at closing the achievement gap, right? They wanted to reach and educate inner city children,
它的侧面有烟灰。你可以看出它看起来就像一条真实的城市街道。他们没有美化它。但在某种程度上，纽约市的街区确实是斯通和库尼唯一能设置像《芝麻街》这样节目的地方。这是因为他们试图触及的目标群体。该节目很大程度上旨在缩小成就差距，对吧？他们想要触及并教育内城的孩子们，
impoverished children. And the way to do that, according to Stone, is to create this environment that they're familiar with. He wanted to create an environment that would look familiar to them and look like home to them. But what's going on is not riots and crime and all this awful stuff. It's this like harmonious, integrated, happy little village where people get along. And if they have problems, they will resolve them with each other.
贫困的孩子们。据斯通说，实现这一目标的方法是创造一个他们熟悉的环境。他想创造一个看起来让他们熟悉、看起来像家的环境。但发生的不是骚乱、犯罪和所有那些可怕的事情。而是一个和谐、融合、快乐的小村庄，人们和睦相处。如果他们遇到问题，他们会互相解决。
During a time when the city's reputation was mixed at best, Sesame Street deliberately chose to portray the more positive aspects of living in a place like New York City. It depicted an inner city neighborhood that worked. And in doing so, the show found itself aligned with the ideas of one of the most prominent advocates of vibrant urban communities. The writer and activist, Jane Jacobs. Some things are said so often that nobody thinks of what they mean anymore. For instance, for years we've been hearing, take the children off the streets, off the streets and into where? Although we haven't had a specific Jane Jacobs episode of 99PI,
在城市声誉充其量只能说是毁誉参半的时代，《芝麻街》刻意选择了描绘像纽约市这样地方更积极的一面。它描绘了一个运作良好的内城社区。通过这样做，该节目发现自己与最具活力的城市社区倡导者之一——作家兼活动家简·雅各布斯的理念不谋而合。有些话被说得太频繁，以至于没人再去思考它们的含义。例如，多年来我们一直听到：“让孩子们离开街道”，离开街道去哪儿呢？虽然我们还没有制作过专门关于简·雅各布斯的《99PI》剧集，
Her influence touches nearly every story we cover on the show. Jacobs wasn't an urban planner at all. She was a resident of Greenwich Village who saw firsthand how slum clearance and revitalization efforts in the 1950s devastated communities. Instead, she championed mixed-use pedestrian-friendly cities and a community-based approach to urban planning. Jane Jacobs is this great observer of urban life. She's an expert noticeer of what's going on in the city. she's just paying attention to things in her own neighborhood in Manhattan, and she's writing down all these interactions that a lot of people are familiar with, but have kind of taken for granted.
但她的影响力触及了我们在节目中报道的几乎每一个故事。雅各布斯根本不是城市规划师。她是格林威治村的一名居民，亲眼目睹了20世纪50年代的贫民窟清理和振兴工作如何摧毁了社区。相反，她倡导混合用途、适合步行的城市以及基于社区的城市规划方法。简·雅各布斯是一位伟大的城市生活观察者。她是城市中正在发生的事情的专家级观察者。她只是关注自己曼哈顿社区里的事情，并写下了许多人们熟悉但被视为理所当然的互动。
In 1961, Jacobs compiled these observations and released a book called The Death and Life of Great American Cities. It's just one of those books that becomes part of the zeitgeist. It is hugely popular, hugely influential. The same way the concepts from the feminine mystique are in the air. The concepts from this book are also in the air. It's like the Bible for urbanness. In the book, Jacobs took aim at urban planners like Robert Moses, who didn't understand how neighborhoods actually functioned.
1961年，雅各布斯整理了这些观察结果，出版了一本名为《美国大城市的死与生》的书。它是那种成为时代精神一部分的书。它非常受欢迎，影响力巨大。就像《女性的奥秘》中的概念在当时广为流传一样，这本书中的概念也同样深入人心。它就像城市规划的圣经。在书中，雅各布斯将矛头指向了罗伯特·摩西等城市规划师，他们并不了解社区实际上是如何运作的。
Instead of bulldozing, rebuilding, and further segregating neighborhoods, she believed that city planners should consider the needs of the residents. Suppose we actually let the sidewalks do the job that they can do best. And suppose we stopped trying to provide poor substitutes for them. The death and life of great American cities was almost a love letter to what the city was already doing right. And in it, she identified a set of conditions that she observed every thriving city was built on. And because the creators of Sesame Street were depicting what a healthy urban neighborhood looks like, you can actually see Jane Jacobs' principles playing out as you watch the show.
她认为，城市规划者不应推土机式地重建和进一步隔离社区，而应考虑居民的需求。假设我们真的让街道发挥它们最擅长的作用。假设我们停止尝试为它们提供拙劣的替代品。《美国大城市的死与生》几乎是一封写给城市已经在做正确之事的“情书”。书中，她确定了一系列她观察到的每个繁荣城市所建立的条件。由于《芝麻街》的创作者们正在描绘一个健康的城市社区是什么样子，当你观看节目时，你实际上可以看到简·雅各布斯的原则在发挥作用。
Sesame Street ends up being this blueprint for a Jane Jacobsian utopia almost. You have so many different principles that she outlined in her book play out on that actual block. And I think that's because the actual block of Sesame Street very closely mirrors a real New York block. This next section is brought to you by the number four, because there are four different conditions that Jane's Jane Jacobs believed were key to a vibrant block, starting with condition number one. A neighborhood should have multiple functions. I mean, it's a mixed-use neighborhood. You have your laundromat. You have your convenience store, grocery store. You have a multifamily apartment building. You have everything you need there. It'll never be totally dead and empty. Like, you'll have people.
《芝麻街》最终几乎成为了简·雅各布斯式乌托邦的蓝图。她在书中概述的许多不同原则都在那个真实的街区中体现出来。我认为这是因为《芝麻街》的实际街区非常接近真实的纽约街区。接下来的部分由数字“4”赞助，因为简·雅各布斯认为有四个不同的条件是充满活力的街区的关键，从条件一开始：一个社区应该具备多种功能。我的意思是，这是一个混合用途的社区。你有自助洗衣店。你有便利店、杂货店。你有公寓楼。你所需的一切都在那里。它永远不会完全死气沉沉。你会有人
going off to work, but then you'll have someone coming in to go shopping, and then you'll have people like kids out on the street playing. It'll always kind of be lively that way. Condition number two. City blocks should be short. The beauty of the blocks being short, especially on Sesame Street, is that you have more contact with people in a real city, too. That's the case, right? When blocks are shorter, it allows for many different paths and many different experiences and many different casual encounters for pedestrians. You're turning corners all the time.
去上班，但随后会有人进来购物，然后你会看到孩子们在街上玩耍。它总是会以那种方式充满活力。条件二：城市街区应该短。街区短的好处，特别是在《芝麻街》中，是你与人的接触更多，在真实的城市中也是如此，对吧？当街区较短时，它允许行人有许多不同的路径、许多不同的体验和许多不同的偶然相遇。你一直在转弯，
and you're seeing new things. And it's just more, I'm trying to think of a better way to say it, but it's more dynamic that way. Condition number three. There's a need for old buildings, new buildings, and old buildings must mingle in a single district. In case you didn't quite catch that, the third condition is there is a need for aged buildings. And both old and new buildings must mingle together in a single district. This is because new buildings are expensive. and rent reflects construction costs.
看到新的事物。它更具活力。条件三：需要旧建筑，新建筑和旧建筑必须在同一个区域内融合。以防你没听清，第三个条件是需要老建筑，而且新旧建筑必须在同一个区域内融合。这是因为新建筑很贵，租金反映了建筑成本。
If a neighborhood only has new buildings, the cost drives out diversity of businesses and people who can afford to stay there. You could see this dynamic playing out on Sesame Street. There was a redesign in the 90s, and the set designers added a new hotel, a new apartment building, and the brownstone was still there, and one of the designers at the time said it was,
如果一个社区只有新建筑，成本就会驱逐多样化的企业和负担得起留在那里的居民。你可以在《芝麻街》中看到这种动态。90年代进行了一次重新设计，布景设计师增加了一家新酒店、一栋新公寓楼，而褐砂石建筑依然存在，当时的一位设计师说，
and this is his quote, he said it was meant to look like a survivor of gentrification. But I say that to say you have this mix of the new and the old on Sesame Street. Condition number four. Don't want it to get you anymore. You're just making me say stuff. Why can I say whatever I want? Our kid narrators are clearly coming apart at the seams, so I'll handle this last one.
这是他的原话，他说它看起来像是士绅化的幸存者。但我说这些是为了说明在《芝麻街》上你有这种新旧融合。条件四：不想再让你说了。你只是在让我说这些。为什么我可以随心所欲地说？我们的儿童旁白显然快要崩溃了，所以我来处理最后一个。
The fourth condition is that a neighborhood should have a dense concentration of people. This is key to a healthy city because high density supports the local businesses of a mixed-use neighborhood. and having more eyes on the streets helps keep them safer. Like all of these principles are intertwined, right? Like the dense concentration of people also goes hand in hand with the neighborhood serving multiple functions. Like you have people just living there and maybe doing their laundry. And then you also have people working there like Mr. Hooper. So there's always at any given time a lot of people there.
第四个条件是社区应该有密集的人口。这对健康的城市至关重要，因为高密度支持混合用途社区的本地企业。而且街上有更多的人关注，有助于保持安全。就像所有这些原则都是交织在一起的，对吧？比如密集的人口也与社区服务多种功能相辅相成。比如你有人住在那里，可能在洗衣服。然后你也有人在那里工作，比如胡珀先生。所以无论何时，那里总是有很多人。
Jacobs believe that when these four conditions come together, cities become safer, more economically stable, more diverse, and more alive. and that when that happens, you can see it all unfolding on the sidewalk level. Jacobs even identified a type of spontaneous dance that pedestrians unknowingly perform when all these elements align. The sidewalk ballet. The sidewalk ballet is the term that Jane Jacobs coined to refer to all of those casual, improvised interactions that will happen in the public sphere of the sidewalk. It's the systematic dance of neighbors, shopkeepers, kids, workers, and strangers moving through shared space, recognizing familiar faces, having spontaneous conversations, and watching out for one another.
雅各布斯认为，当这四个条件结合在一起时，城市会变得更安全、更经济稳定、更多样化、更有活力。当这种情况发生时，你可以在人行道层面看到这一切的展开。雅各布斯甚至确定了一种当所有这些元素对齐时，行人会在不知不觉中表演的自发舞蹈：人行道芭蕾。人行道芭蕾是简·雅各布斯创造的一个术语，指代在人行道公共领域发生的所有那些随意的、即兴的互动。这是邻居、店主、孩子、工人和陌生人在共享空间中移动、识别熟悉的面孔、进行自发对话并互相照应的系统性舞蹈。
It's the visible manifestation of a neighborhood that's working the way it should. You can think about walking down a city block and you'll see a mom pushing a stroller. You'll see the shopkeeper like rolling up their gate and opening for the day. You'll see someone walking their dog. Maybe you see a neighbor you know. And it's all of these people passing you by and maybe you're saying hello. We actually see the sidewalk ballet playing out in the very first scene of the very first episode of Sesame Street. Sally, you've never seen a street like Sesame Street.
这是社区以应有方式运作的可见表现。你可以想象走在城市街区，你会看到一位推着婴儿车的母亲。你会看到店主拉开闸门开始新的一天。你会看到有人在遛狗。也许你看到了认识的邻居。所有这些人从你身边经过，也许你在打招呼。我们实际上在《芝麻街》第一集的第一幕中就看到了人行道芭蕾的上演。莎莉，你从来没见过像芝麻街这样的街道。
Everything happens here. You're going to love it. Gordon is one of the few human characters on the show. And he owns the 1-2-3 Sesame Street Brownstone with his wife, Susan. In this first scene, Gordon is showing a new neighbor, a young girl named Sally, around the block. And he's like, hi, there's Mr. Hooper. Oh, there's Big Bird. Hello, Big Bird. Oh, hi, Gordon.
这里什么都会发生。你会喜欢它的。戈登是节目中为数不多的人类角色之一。他和妻子苏珊拥有芝麻街123号的褐砂石建筑。在这一幕中，戈登正带着一位名叫莎莉的小女孩参观街区。他说：嗨，那是胡珀先生。哦，那是大鸟。你好，大鸟。哦，嗨，戈登。
How are you? A man buys a newspaper from Mr. Hooper. Gordon's wife, Susan, pops her head out of the window to say hello. Oh, you just moved in, huh? Yeah. Well, will you come back and see me later and have some milk and cookies with me? Okay, I'll see you later. You're seeing children play on the street, and it's like the quintessential.
你好吗？一个人从胡珀先生那里买了一份报纸。戈登的妻子苏珊从窗户探出头来打招呼。哦，你刚搬进来，是吗？是的。好吧，你以后回来看看我，和我一起喝牛奶吃饼干好吗？好的，我稍后再见。你看到孩子们在街上玩耍，这简直就是典型的
sidewalk ballet. Just little moments of human interaction that are unplanned and pretty minor, but altogether they make you feel like you're part of something greater. And we see that all the time on Sesame Street. Jane Jacobs, much like the characters on Sesame Street, taught us that a strong neighborhood can't just be built from the top down, and that, quote, cities have the capability of providing something for everybody, only because and only when they are created by everybody. end quote. But of course, not every urban planner bought into this community-driven vision. And while Jane Jacobs came up against Robert Moses, Sesame Street faced Ronald Grump. Mr. Grump, we want to talk to you about your plans for Sesame Street.
人行道芭蕾。只是那些非计划的、相当微小的人类互动瞬间，但总的来说，它们让你觉得你是更宏大事物的一部分。我们在《芝麻街》中一直看到这一点。简·雅各布斯和《芝麻街》中的角色一样，教导我们一个强大的社区不能仅仅从上而下地建立，而且“城市有能力为每个人提供一些东西，只有因为且只有当它们由每个人创造时”。但当然，并非每一位城市规划师都认同这种社区驱动的愿景。当简·雅各布斯对抗罗伯特·摩西时，《芝麻街》也面临着罗纳德·格朗普。格朗普先生，我们想和你谈谈你对芝麻街的计划。
My plans? See for yourself. Out of the ruins of Sesame Street rises the gleaming tower of Grump. Where's one, two, three, Sesame Street? I'm glad you asked that. It is now a luxurious boutique called, if you have to ask, you cannot afford it. Yes, that is the voice of Joe Pesci playing Ronald Grump. Ronald Grump is a real estate developer, perhaps inspired by someone in the real world. And he's played by Joe Pesci and he comes on to Sesame Street.
我的计划？你自己看吧。在芝麻街的废墟上，升起了格朗普闪闪发光的塔楼。芝麻街123号在哪里？我很高兴你问这个问题。它现在是一家豪华精品店，名字叫“如果你必须问，你就买不起”。是的，那是乔·佩西扮演罗纳德·格朗普的声音。罗纳德·格朗普是一位房地产开发商，灵感可能来自现实世界中的某个人。他由乔·佩西扮演，来到了芝麻街。
And he's got these plans for this glamorous new tower that he wants to build. And all the Muppets start freaking out. And they're like, what do we do? We're going to get kicked out of our homes. You can't do this to Sesame Street. It's a special place. Of course, because this is a children's show, the residents of Sesame Street were eventually able to overcome the terrible Ronald Grump and save their brownstone. But it isn't just the characters on Sesame Street who have faced existential threats.
他带着他想建造的华丽新塔楼的计划。所有的布偶都开始惊慌失措。他们说：我们该怎么办？我们要被赶出家园了。你不能对芝麻街这样做。这是一个特别的地方。当然，因为这是一个儿童节目，《芝麻街》的居民最终能够克服可怕的罗纳德·格朗普并拯救他们的褐砂石建筑。但不仅仅是《芝麻街》的角色面临生存威胁。
The show itself has had to navigate several over the years. Since Sesame Street is partly funded by public money and depicts a diverse cast in an urban setting, It's been accused of being overtly political. I was looking specifically when I was researching this article, criticism of the set in particular. And the main thing I found on that was from the right-wing pundit Ben Shapiro, of course. And he called the set dingy. So this is what he said. Unlike other children's shows, Sesame Street took place in a dingy setting, an urban neighborhood street.
该节目本身多年来也必须应对几次威胁。由于《芝麻街》部分由公共资金资助，并在城市环境中描绘了多元化的演员阵容，它被指责为过于政治化。我在研究这篇文章时，特别关注了对布景的批评。我发现的主要内容来自右翼评论员本·夏皮罗。他称布景“肮脏”。他是这样说的：与其他儿童节目不同，《芝麻街》发生在一个肮脏的环境中，一条城市街区街道。
One of the characters, Oscar the Grouch, lived in a garbage can. And then he also says that the show is about legitimizing urban liberal lifestyles. It really seems like he's viewing any urban block, even a fictional one, as part of this big city liberal kind of idea. Because the show has been such a beloved institution for over half a century, Sesame Street has been somewhat immune to attacks like these. But right now, public media. is under threat. And Sesame Street has gotten caught up in a cultural war with a lot of casualties. I think there was a point where people would be too scared to touch something as beloved as Sesame Street. But the fear of that has gone out the window pretty much.
其中一个角色，奥斯卡，住在垃圾桶里。然后他还说该节目是在使城市自由派生活方式合法化。他似乎把任何城市街区，即使是虚构的，都视为这种大城市自由派理念的一部分。因为该节目半个多世纪以来一直是一个深受喜爱的机构，《芝麻街》在某种程度上对这类攻击具有免疫力。但现在，公共媒体正受到威胁。《芝麻街》陷入了一场伤亡惨重的文化战争。我想曾经有一段时间，人们会因为害怕而不敢触碰像《芝麻街》这样深受喜爱的节目。但那种恐惧感几乎已经消失了。
Sesame Street is facing probably its biggest challenge in decades, which is a shame. Because at a time when Americans increasingly don't know their neighbors and communities feel more fractured than ever, Sesame Street still shows us something different, a block where people of all backgrounds actually talk to each other, look out for each other, share space not just peacefully, but joyfully. That vision feels almost radical now. And maybe depicting that gap between idealism and reality has always been the point. You know, I think Sesame Street is very idealistic. I think the creators wanted to give children a vision of how urban life could be.
《芝麻街》正面临几十年来可能最大的挑战，这很遗憾。因为在当今美国人越来越不了解邻居、社区感觉比以往任何时候都更加分裂的时代，《芝麻街》仍然向我们展示了不同的东西：一个来自各种背景的人们真正交谈、互相照顾、不仅和平而且快乐地共享空间的街区。这种愿景现在感觉几乎是激进的。也许描绘理想主义与现实之间的差距一直就是重点。你知道，我认为《芝麻街》非常理想主义。我认为创作者们想给孩子们一个城市生活应有样子的愿景。
But there's also a power within that kind of idealism, I would say. The strongest example of that idealism came from the actor Loretta Long, who played Susan, the owner of the 123 Sesame Street Brownstone. And this is what she said in her memoir. Not only were we a black married couple, we all. also owned that house. We had some strange tenants like Big Bird, Oscar the Grouch, and Ernie and Burt, but we were landlords, which was not the typical case for black families on television. And I think that kind of tells you why it's important to be idealistic at times. It's already
但我认为那种理想主义中也有一种力量。这种理想主义最强有力的例子来自演员洛蕾塔·朗，她饰演了芝麻街123号褐砂石建筑的主人苏珊。她在回忆录中这样写道：我们不仅是一对黑人已婚夫妇，我们还拥有那栋房子。我们有一些奇怪的租户，比如大鸟、奥斯卡、厄尼和伯特，但我们是房东，这在电视上的黑人家庭中并不常见。我认为这说明了为什么有时保持理想主义很重要。这已经
a show that has little monsters running around, right? Like, why not show something like Black Home Ownership? The stories we tell our children shape what they believe is positive. So whether those stories are that they deserve to own a home one day or that they have the power to build better cities or that kindness matters, luckily we have Sesame Street to tell them. After the break, I speak with architecture critic Alexander Lang about her Pulitzer Prize winning essays on children and urban spaces. Stay with us. Welcome back. All this talk about Sesame Street has got us thinking more about kids and designs.
是一个有小怪兽跑来跑去的节目，对吧？那么为什么不展示像“黑人拥有住房”这样的东西呢？我们告诉孩子的故事塑造了他们的信仰。所以，无论这些故事是关于他们有一天理应拥有自己的房子，还是他们有能力建设更好的城市，或者善良很重要，幸运的是，我们有《芝麻街》来告诉他们。休息之后，我将与建筑评论家亚历山大·朗谈谈她关于儿童和城市空间的普利策奖获奖文章。请留下来。欢迎回来。所有关于《芝麻街》的讨论让我们更多地思考孩子和设计。
We wanted to have frequent contributor Alexander Lang back on the show. She is the author of The Design of Childhood. And like me, Alexandra loves Sesame Street. She told us her favorite moment is the cartoon where a mother sends her kid to the grocery store for three very specific items. Now don't forget, a loaf of bread, a container of milk, and a stick of butter. I won't forget. I remember. A loaf of bread, a container of milk, and a stick of butter. A loaf of bread, a container of milk, and a stick of butter.
我们想请常驻撰稿人亚历山大·朗回到节目中。她是《童年的设计》一书的作者。像我一样，亚历山德拉也喜欢《芝麻街》。她告诉我们她最喜欢的片段是那个卡通：一位母亲派孩子去杂货店买三样非常具体的东西。“现在别忘了，一条面包，一盒牛奶，一根黄油。”“我不会忘的。”“我记得。一条面包，一盒牛奶，一根黄油。一条面包，一盒牛奶，一根黄油。”
Mr. Could I have a loss of bread, a container of milk, and, hey, I can't remember. You know, so much of what I write about is about giving children independence, like it's right there in the subtitle of my book. And this little clip just, I feel, perfectly illustrates why it's so empowering for kids to have independence. Like, the kid is so fixed on this activity. Like, we've all seen kids try, you know, so hard to be just that much more grown up and giving them opportunities like this to be independent. Like, that's, it illustrates it perfectly. So, Alexandra, you hold the record for the most appearances of a guest expert on 99. percent invisible. And a lot has happened since the last time we had you won, including that you won
“先生，我能要一条面包，一盒牛奶，还有，嘿，我记不起来了。”你知道，我写的大部分内容都是关于给予孩子独立性，就像我书的副标题里写的那样。我觉得这个小片段完美地说明了为什么让孩子拥有独立性是如此赋能。孩子对这项活动如此专注。我们都见过孩子努力想要变得更成熟，给他们这样的机会去独立，这完美地说明了这一点。所以，亚历山德拉，你是《99%隐形》中客座专家出场次数最多的纪录保持者。自上次你来之后发生了很多事，包括你赢得了
the Pulitzer Prize for Criticism, which is amazing. Congratulations. Thank you. It still feels quite unbelievable to me, too. And specifically, you won the Pulitzer Prize for your writing about design and childhood. That's right. Yeah. It was a whole series for Bloomberg City Lab on building more family-friendly cities. Nice. Well, congratulations again. It's This is so much fun to watch your success. And I love your work. And that's why you're on so much. And so it's a delight to see other people recognize it and enjoy it as much as we do. So, but I want to talk a little bit about design and childhood while we're in this space of Sesame Street and urban spaces. And one of the things you identify in your reporting in particular is that there's a lot of design that's hostile to teens. Like young children get a little bit of support, respectable adults. get some support in public spaces. Teens have lots of places cut off to them, particularly in public spaces.
普利策评论奖，这太棒了。恭喜。谢谢。对我来说，这仍然感觉相当不可思议。特别是，你凭借关于设计和童年的写作赢得了普利策奖。没错。是的，那是为彭博社“城市实验室”撰写的一系列关于建设更适合家庭的城市的文章。太好了。再次恭喜。看到你的成功真是太有趣了。我喜欢你的作品，这就是为什么你经常来。看到其他人像我们一样认可并欣赏它，真是令人高兴。所以，我想在《芝麻街》和城市空间这个话题下，谈谈设计和童年。你在报道中特别指出的事情之一是，有很多设计对青少年是不友好的。比如幼儿得到了一点支持，受人尊敬的成年人在公共空间得到了一些支持。青少年在公共空间中有很多地方被拒之门外。
Could you talk about that problem? It's like playgrounds by and large are designed for children from zero to 12. And parents and caregivers get really uncomfortable if teenagers come into those playgrounds and start getting loud, start climbing on the play equipment in some ways that are unorthodox. And meanwhile, you know, adults who run corner stores, you know, adults who run other kinds of
你能谈谈这个问题吗？总的来说，游乐场是为0到12岁的儿童设计的。如果青少年进入这些游乐场并开始大声喧哗、以非正统的方式攀爬游乐设施，父母和看护人会感到非常不舒服。与此同时，你知道，经营街角商店的成年人，经营其他类型
semi-public places also don't want teens hanging out because they think they're not going to spend money and they're also going to scare off the adults. And then on top of all of that, people keep saying, you know, teenagers in America are having a mental health crisis and don't exercise enough and don't leave the house and are playing too many video games. And it's just like, really, like, what do you want the teenagers to do? Where do you want them to go? And so, yeah, I've tried a lot in my work to advocate for teenagers not being scary, but also to describe the kind of places that teenagers actually like and, you know, kind of might want to be out there in the world. And one of the places you describe in your book was designed by a design studio called
半公共场所的成年人也不希望青少年在那里闲逛，因为他们认为青少年不会花钱，而且会吓跑成年人。最重要的是，人们一直在说，你知道，美国的青少年正经历心理健康危机，锻炼不足，不出门，玩太多电子游戏。这真是……你到底想让青少年做什么？你想让他们去哪里？所以，是的，我在工作中尝试了很多，倡导青少年并不吓人，同时也描述了青少年真正喜欢的、可能想在世界上出现的地方。你在书中描述的其中一个地方是由一家名为
WRT Design. They made an amenity that goes against. this trend of excluding teens and, you know, made a park or designed a park that was really kind of teen-friendly. Actually, it's kind of open to all people, but the fact that it focuses a little bit on teens is what's particularly notable about it. And it was this FDR Park in Philadelphia. So what did they make? So, yeah, it's the Anna C Verna playground in FDR Park, which was designed by WRT and Studio Ludo, who are kind of a playground design expert firm. And the object that they designed they call the mega swing, which is this amazing swing set that is a 120 by 100 foot ellipse that has 20 swings hanging from it and a seating area in the middle. And basically it takes
WRT Design的设计工作室设计的。他们创造了一种设施，违背了这种排斥青少年的趋势，设计了一个真正对青少年友好的公园。实际上，它对所有人开放，但它稍微关注青少年这一事实特别值得注意。这就是费城的FDR公园。那么他们做了什么？是的，那是FDR公园里的安娜·C·弗纳游乐场，由WRT和Studio Ludo设计，后者是一家游乐场设计专家公司。他们设计的物体被称为“超级秋千”，这是一个令人惊叹的秋千组合，是一个120乘100英尺的椭圆形，上面挂着20个秋千，中间有一个休息区。基本上它采用了
your ordinary playground swing and like jacks it up beyond anything that most people can imagine. And the swing set also has five different types of swings for basically like, any ability level, most of which can be used communally or in groups. So the idea is really making the swing into a social space that is also physically challenging and kind of like a puzzle to solve as you figure out like how to get higher, stronger, faster on any one of the swings. Yeah, they have ones that are kind of like a two person swing that kind of function together. They have there's ones that the with the netting. I've seen these more commonly that You can kind of lay down in.
你普通的游乐场秋千，并将其提升到大多数人无法想象的程度。这个秋千组合还有五种不同类型的秋千，基本上适合任何能力水平，其中大多数可以集体或分组使用。所以这个想法确实是把秋千变成了一个社交空间，同时也具有身体挑战性，当你弄清楚如何在任何一个秋千上荡得更高、更强、更快时，它就像一个需要解决的谜题。是的，他们有那种两人秋千，可以一起玩。还有那种带网的，我更常见到这种，你可以躺在上面。
Yeah. It looks delightful and inviting and kind of amazing. Yeah, it really is because, I mean, I went there once and there was a group of teenagers who all piled on one of the adaptive swings, which are those molded plastic kind of heavy duty swings, you know, intended for people with disabilities. But they piled like four different people on it, like standing up and sitting down. began rocking it, like really fast, back and forth, back and forth, and then jumping off when it reached the height. So it's like somehow, like making this swing into a slightly unfamiliar object, I think, also really fires up people's imaginations on like, oh, okay, I don't have to swing in just one way. And maybe I want to swing with my friends. And, you know, it becomes a whole story in itself.
是的。它看起来既令人愉快又诱人，而且非常棒。是的，确实如此，因为我曾经去过那里，有一群青少年挤在一个无障碍秋千上，那是那种模压塑料的重型秋千，你知道，是为残疾人准备的。但他们挤了四个人在上面，站着坐着都有。开始摇晃它，非常快，来回摇晃，然后在达到高度时跳下来。所以，以某种方式将这个秋千变成一个稍微陌生的物体，我认为也真正激发了人们的想象力，比如：哦，好吧，我不必只用一种方式荡秋千。也许我想和朋友一起荡。你知道，它本身就变成了一个完整的故事。
Yeah. What does a swing in particular provide that other sort of apparatus or other sort of amenities in out of a park doesn't provide for teens. Well, when people are thinking of park provisions for teens, usually they're thinking about like sports courts, especially like basketball courts, or they're thinking about skate parks. But not every teenager, you know, wants to, wants to ball or wants to skate. And the swings really open up another avenue for physical activity, but also for social
是的。秋千特别能提供什么其他公园设施无法为青少年提供的功能？嗯，当人们考虑为青少年提供公园设施时，通常会想到运动场，特别是篮球场，或者滑板公园。但并不是每个青少年都想打球或滑板。秋千确实为体育活动开辟了另一条途径，但也为社交
activity because swings can just be something that you can sit on and chat with a friend. If you want to be outside, you want to be in public, you want to be hanging out, but you don't want to do either of those specific sports activities. Yeah. And, you know, why is a large Megasween like a good way to attract teens? Like you wouldn't necessarily assume they'd be drawn to that, but what does it work? I think because older kids and teens don't necessarily want to I'll use something that looks like it's been designed for kids. But the designers of this playground were very careful. Like, there isn't a lot of plastic.
活动提供了途径，因为秋千可以是你坐下来和朋友聊天的地方。如果你想在户外，想在公共场合，想闲逛，但又不想做那些特定的体育活动。是的。而且，为什么像大型超级秋千这样的东西是吸引青少年的好方法？你不会必然假设他们会被吸引，但它为什么有效？我认为是因为大孩子和青少年不一定想使用看起来是为小孩子设计的东西。但这个游乐场的设计师非常小心。没有太多的塑料。
There aren't a lot of bright colors. You know, everything is kind of nature-toned, stainless steel. So it doesn't necessarily scream this is for kids. You know, I'm never really thought about that. Like, the bright colors are these sort of attractive, you know, beacons for little kids. But they're kind of not exactly repulsive to teens, but they're kind of indicators is that teens shouldn't be there. Yeah.
没有太多的鲜艳颜色。你知道，一切都是自然色调，不锈钢。所以它不一定会尖叫“这是给孩子用的”。你知道，我从来没想过这一点。鲜艳的颜色是吸引小孩子的灯塔。但它们对青少年来说并不完全排斥，但它们是一种指标，表明青少年不应该在那里。是的。
I mean, you can even see that, like, as you look at the clothes from, like, the children to the preteen to the teen section, right? All the color gets leached out. We've coded the bright primary colors as things for kids. And so if you're a teenager and you're, you know, trying to make sure that people understand you're not a baby, you don't necessarily want to go and play on those things. So you write that most playgrounds are built just for kids and they always include these four Ss, which are, swings, slides, seesaws, and sandboxes, and we're all very used to seeing these things on a playground. But how is that changing? Well, unfortunately, the sandbox and the seesaw are becoming somewhat endangered. Sandboxes because they're very high maintenance and seesaws also
我的意思是，你甚至可以看到，当你观察从儿童到青春期再到青少年部分的衣服时，对吧？所有的颜色都被过滤掉了。我们将明亮的基色编码为儿童的东西。所以如果你是一个青少年，并且你正在努力确保人们明白你不是婴儿，你不一定想去玩那些东西。所以你写道，大多数游乐场只是为孩子建造的，它们总是包括这四个S：秋千（Swings）、滑梯（Slides）、跷跷板（Seesaws）和沙坑（Sandboxes），我们都非常习惯在游乐场看到这些东西。但这有什么变化吗？嗯，不幸的是，沙坑和跷跷板正变得有些濒危。沙坑是因为它们维护成本很高，跷跷板也是。
because of fall dangers. But I'm happy to see some of these swings that kind of replicate the seesaw motion so that kids can still have that like we've got to work together feeling but they're considered so much safer than the old-fashioned like wood plank seesaws. I would say, you know, also now we see, you know, more different types of climbing structures like so many, you know, rope ladders, rope netting, big round kind of rope balls. And those can be really fun and challenging. And I think that those replace things like the old-fashioned jungle gym, but they are a lot safer and they can actually, you know, go a lot higher than those old structures could. I love seeing those. I want to climb on those when I see these large rope ladder structures.
因为有跌落的危险。但我很高兴看到一些秋千模仿了跷跷板的动作，这样孩子们仍然可以体验那种“我们需要合作”的感觉，而且它们被认为比老式的木板跷跷板安全得多。我想说，现在我们也看到了更多不同类型的攀爬结构，比如各种绳梯、绳网、巨大的圆形绳球。这些设施既有趣又具有挑战性。我认为它们取代了老式的攀爬架，但它们安全得多，而且实际上比那些旧结构能爬得更高。我喜欢看到这些。当我看到这些大型绳梯结构时，我也想上去爬一爬。
I'm often specifically excluded with, you know, by a signage that says people without children can't go into the space, you know. But they look amazing. They look so fun. They can be really fun. I mean, I have climbed on many structures. So sometimes you just got to go after all the parents with small children have left the playground because they're the ones who are going to report you. But yeah, they can be really fun. I mean, I think there's a reason, you know, climbing gyms are really popular now.
我经常被那些写着“无儿童者不得入内”的标牌拒之门外。但它们看起来太棒了，看起来很有趣。它们确实可以非常有趣。我的意思是，我爬过很多这样的结构。所以有时候你只能等所有带小孩的家长离开游乐场后再去，因为他们才是会举报你的人。但确实，它们可以非常有趣。我认为攀岩馆现在如此受欢迎是有原因的。
Everyone wants to climb. It's a whole body exercise. There's just something about, you know, getting to the top that is so appealing and just such a natural challenge. Yeah. You know, when I was reading your essay and when I read your work, I think about the closest, the closest park to me in Berkeley is called Kordinesis Park. And it was built in 1915. And it has what I would consider to be a fairly terrifying concrete slide built into the, the landscape. I mean, like, the kids, they're supposed to, I mean, kids, adults alike, you salvage some piece of cardboard and you go to the top, you climb to the top, and you slide this thing down, you go extremely fast. I used to bring my little kids there, and it used
每个人都想攀爬。这是一种全身运动。登顶的感觉非常吸引人，这是一种自然的挑战。是的。你知道，当我读你的文章和作品时，我想到了离我最近的伯克利公园，叫科迪内西斯公园。它建于1915年。它有一个我认为相当可怕的混凝土滑梯，嵌入在景观中。我的意思是，孩子们，我是说，无论是孩子还是大人，你找一块硬纸板，爬到顶端，然后滑下来，速度极快。我过去常带我的小孩子们去那里，它过去
to really, truly terrify me. I used to call it Concussion Park and not, not a court of this park. And so there's this tension that if you do create something that's kind of fun for everyone because playgrounds are sort of designed, 98% of them are designed for little little kids. As soon as you have one that has something that is a little bit more challenging and appeals to adults and teens alike, there is a little bit of attention that the younger kids want to do what the older kids are doing and maybe that's not appropriate. How do you sort of balance all that stuff? It sounds like WRT and those groups, you know, they figured out something. But what are they figuring out? I mean, what they're really figuring out is how to manage
真的让我非常害怕。我过去常叫它“脑震荡公园”，而不是科迪内西斯公园。所以这里存在一种张力：如果你创造了一些对每个人都有趣的东西——因为98%的游乐场都是为小小孩设计的——一旦你拥有了一个更具挑战性、同时吸引成人和青少年的设施，就会产生一点矛盾，因为小孩子想模仿大孩子做的事情，而这可能并不合适。你是如何平衡这些问题的？听起来WRT和那些团队似乎找到了解决办法。但他们到底发现了什么？我的意思是，他们真正发现的是如何管理
risk. It's really important for kids to engage in risky play, which does not necessarily mean dangerous play. But if you think about how we learn to do things, you usually have to try to do something and fail or try to do it and just not get it quite right. And that's really what risky play is, you know, for the body. It's like, okay, I see all the big kids going down this slide. Like, I've been watching them. I want to do it too. But can I also absorb the lessons about, like, how you dismount from the slide, like, how you should position your body on that piece of cardboard. Maybe the first time I do it, I don't want to use cardboard because I can see if you just go down on your clothes, it's actually, like, slower than the cardboard.
风险。让孩子们参与冒险游戏非常重要，这并不一定意味着危险游戏。但如果你思考我们是如何学习做事的，你通常必须尝试去做某事，然后失败，或者尝试去做但做得不够好。这就是冒险游戏对身体的意义。就像，“好吧，我看到所有大孩子都从这个滑梯滑下去。我一直在观察他们。我也想试试。”但我能同时吸收关于如何从滑梯上下来、如何把身体放在那块硬纸板上的经验吗？也许第一次尝试时，我不想用硬纸板，因为我能看出如果直接用衣服滑，其实比用硬纸板慢。
So, like, A, exposing kids to, like, giving them the opportunity to watch other people do it and learn some lessons from observation is great. But also at a certain point, you just have to let them do it because if they don't do it, they will never learn how to do it safely. And then you're actually, you know, inhibiting their growth and independence. So, yeah, I mean, there's been a lot of discussion in psychological circles about how kids really don't have enough opportunities for risky play. So these new fangled playgrounds are trying to push the limits on what is allowed by safety regulations, but also will give kids opportunities to do something they've never done before. Yeah. And for the record, I did let my kids go down the slide. I overcame my own fear to allow that
所以，A，让孩子们有机会观察别人并从中学习经验是非常棒的。但同时，在某个时刻，你必须让他们去尝试，因为如果他们不尝试，他们就永远学不会如何安全地去做。那样你实际上是在抑制他们的成长和独立性。所以，心理学界有很多讨论，认为孩子们确实没有足够的冒险游戏机会。因此，这些新式游乐场正试图在安全法规允许的范围内挑战极限，同时也给孩子们提供尝试从未做过的事情的机会。是的。顺便说一句，我确实让我孩子们滑了那个滑梯。我克服了自己的恐惧，允许了这件事
to happen. Yes. But it did make me nervous every single time. Well, I mean, have you watched the video of the cop slide in Boston? No. Do you know about that? No, I don't. Okay. So, When they remodeled the big plaza outside Boston City Hall a couple of years ago, they put in a playground right next to City Hall, which I think is amazing symbolically. And there is a long metal slide as part of that playground that goes down a hill. And gosh, I think it was two years ago, there was this viral video of a policeman going down the slide. And he goes down the slide and he just shoots out the end like a bullet. And all of these people were like, oh, my God, what happened? And the truth was, the cop did not know how to use the slide.
发生。是的。但这确实让我每次都感到紧张。嗯，你看过波士顿那个警察滑滑梯的视频吗？没有。你知道那件事吗？不知道。好吧，几年前当他们翻新波士顿市政厅外的大广场时，他们在市政厅旁边建了一个游乐场，我认为这在象征意义上很棒。那个游乐场里有一个长长的金属滑梯，顺着山坡而下。天哪，我想是两年前，有一个警察滑滑梯的视频疯传。他滑下去的时候，像子弹一样从末端冲了出来。所有人都惊呼：“天哪，发生了什么？”事实是，那个警察根本不知道怎么用那个滑梯。
The cop was, like, heavier than a child, was wearing a polyester uniform and, like, hadn't been on a slide in years. So he was not using the slide right. Plenty of children had used the slide safely. I went and used the slide, because I go on slides all the time. I used it perfectly safely. But it became this kind of viral moment, like, oh, my God, like, what are they doing? doing to the children of these new playgrounds? And it was just that the, like, it was the cop's error, not the playground error. That's a fantastic. Well, it is a pleasure to talk with you.
那个警察比孩子重，穿着聚酯纤维制服，而且好几年没滑过滑梯了。所以他使用滑梯的方法不对。很多孩子都安全地使用过那个滑梯。我也去用了那个滑梯，因为我经常滑。我用得非常安全。但这变成了一个病毒式的时刻，人们都在说：“天哪，这些新游乐场对孩子们做了什么？”其实那只是警察的失误，而不是游乐场的问题。这太精彩了。能和你交谈真是我的荣幸。
I'm so excited by your success and your recognition by the Pulitzer Committee. Thank you so much for speak with me. I enjoyed it. Me too. Thanks again for having me. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Vivian Lay and Chris Barubei. Mix by Martine Gonzalez, music by Swan Real and George Langford. Fact-checking by Sona Avakian. Special thanks this week to our kid narrators, Emma, Fiona, and Eleanor. Kathy, too, is our executive producer. Kirk Colestead is the digital director.
我为你获得的成功和普利策委员会的认可感到非常兴奋。非常感谢你与我交谈。我很享受这次对话。我也是。再次感谢你的邀请。《99% Invisible》本周由Vivian Lay和Chris Barubei制作。混音由Martine Gonzalez完成，音乐由Swan Real和George Langford创作。事实核查由Sona Avakian负责。本周特别感谢我们的儿童旁白Emma、Fiona和Eleanor。Kathy Too是我们的执行制片人。Kirk Colestead是数字总监。
Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason de Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Lashemadonne, Joe Rosenberg, Kelly Prime, Jacob Medina Gleeson, Tallinn, and Rain Stradley, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was, created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Series X-M podcast family,
Delaney Hall是我们的高级编辑。团队的其他成员包括Jason de Leon、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Lashemadonne、Joe Rosenberg、Kelly Prime、Jacob Medina Gleeson、Tallinn和Rain Stradley，以及我，Roman Mars。《99% Invisible》的标志由Stefan Lawrence创作。我们是Series X-M播客家族的一员，
now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our own Discord server. There's a link to that, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站上找到我们，也可以加入我们的Discord服务器。在99PI.org上可以找到相关链接以及《99PI》的所有往期节目。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。